اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مذاكره
رئاسيه تفرض على الحكومات الاجنبيه التي
تتلقى اسلحه امريكيه تقديم ضمانات مكتوبه
بانها ستلتزم بالقانون الدولي والامريكي
تنص المذاكره على ان تقدم الحكومات
الاجنبيه ضمانات بانها ستسهل ولن ترفض نقل
او ايصال المساعده الانسانيه الامريكيه
كما نصت المذاكره ال
كذلك على ان الدول التي لا تلتزم
بالضمانات يمكن ان يتم وقف تصدير الاسلحه
الامريكيه اليه وتطلب المذاكره الرئاسيه
من وزيري الخارجيه والدفاع تقديم تقارير
دوريه للكونجرس للحصول على رقابه ذات معنى
على الاسلحه التي تزود بها امريكا
الحكومات الاجنبيه كما يجب على وزير
الخارجيه او الدفاع وفق هذه المذاكره
ابلاغ الرئيس خلال 45 يوما عن الدول التي
لا تلتزم بالضمانات وتقديم الخطوات
المناسبه لتقييم الوضع وتنص المذاكره
الرئاسيه على انه بعد انتهاء المهله
المحدده سيتم وقف تصدير الاسلحه الامريكيه
حسب الاقتضاء حتى تقدم الدول الضمانات
المطلوبه المذاكره الرئاسيه تستثني من
الضمانات انظمه الدفاع الجوي ومواد الدفاع
الموجهه بشكل صارم لاغراض دفاعيه او التي
تنحصر في الاغراض غير
الفتاكه معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره
محمد الالمي محمد اصدار الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن لهذه المذاكره الرئاسيه في الوقت
الذي على فيه صوته واصبح اكثر حده في
اتجاه الاداء الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه او
انه سلوك تجاوز الحد كما قال ما الذي يقرا
في ثنايا هذه
الخطوات توقيت على قدر كبير من الحساسيه
مريم على اكثر من صعيد اولا يبدو ان الثقه
قد انعدمت نهائيا بين الرئيس الامريكي
ورئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على الرغم من ان
علاقتهما منذ مده طويله وبيننا تنياه مع
الديمقراطيين
اجمالا لم
تكن يعني في افضل حالاتها على مر السنين
التي حكم فيها نتنياهو اسرائيل وبعد عوده
رئيس وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بخوفي حنين
ان صح التعبير من زيارته السادسه لاسرائيل
والرحله المكوكيه الرابعه في المنطقه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر ولم
يفلح بل يبدو ان يبدو انه تعرض لاهانه
علنيه من رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي حينما
اعلن على الملاء انه ماض قدما في هذه
الحرب حتى النصر كما يسميه وايضا عدم
الاستجابه للطلبات الامريكيه من اجل حمايه
المدنيين ومن اجل ادخال مزيد من المساعدات
الانسانيه لاهالي غزه ولم يستجب لاي من
هذه المطالب فضلا عن موضوع حل الدولتين
وال اليوم الذي سيعقب الحرب اذا كان توقيع
هذه المذكره على الرغم من ان القوانين
موجوده اصلا القوانين التي تنص على ان
تحترم الدول التي تتوصل باسلحه امريكيه
القوانين الامريكيه والقوانين الانسانيه
الدوليه لكن واشنطن دابت على تجاهل
تبعات عدم احترام تلك القوانين هذه
المذكره وضعت اليه
للمحاسبه ويبدو ان انها رساله لرئيس
الوزراء
الاسرائيلي على الرغم من ان المذكره تركت
البابه مواربا ان صح التعبير امام
استثناءات حسب مقتضيات الامن القومي
الامريكي المذكره ايضا استجابه لمشرع
ديمقراطيين
18 عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ من اصل 51 عضوا
كانوا يعتزمون اقتراح تعديل على احد
القوان
الذي ستمول به اسرائيل بالاضافه الى
اوكرانيا
وتايوان بضروره احترام اسرائيل تحديدا
وليس كل دول
التي تتوصل باسلحه امريكيه بعد تزايد
القلق لدى هؤلاء من العدد المرعب من
المدنيين الذين يقتلون بسب بسبب ما وصفه
الرئيس بيضا شخصيا بالقصف العشوائي ايضا
يمكن تفسيره على انه ايضا استجابه للضغط
الهائل الذي يواجه الرئيس الامريكي من
القواعد التقليديه للحزب
الديمقراطي من الافارقه الامريكيين طبعا
والعرب المسلمين الامريكيين ومن الجيل
الجديد من الشبان اليهود الامريكيين الذين
يتظاهرون ويطالبون هؤلاء جميعا يطالبون
بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار في غزه وتبدو هذه
الخطوه خجوله للغايه بالمقارنه مع شكرا
محمد
التي يعني يرفعها مؤيد الرئيس الديمقراطي
في وقت سياسي بالغ الحساسيه شكرا جزيلا لك
محمد العلمي كنت معنا من
واشنطن